another fascinating topic you work on is
again also non-traditional to think of
it a security vulnerability but I guess
it is is adversarial machine learning is
basically again high up the stack being
able to attack the the accuracy the
performance of this of machine learning
systems by manipulating some aspect
perhaps actually can clarify but I guess
the traditional way the main way is to
manipulate some the input data to make
the output something totally not
representative of the semantic content
right so in this adversarial machine
meaning essentially attackers the goal
is to fold the Machine system me into
making the wrong decision and the attack
can actually happen at different stages
can happen at the inference stage where
the attacker can manipulates the inputs
perturbations malicious perturbations to
the inputs to cause the machine learning
system to give ground prediction and so
on oh just a pause
what are perturbations also essentially
changes to the inputs from subtle
changes messing with the changes to try
to get a very different output right so
for example the canonical like adversary
example typist you have an image you add
really small perturbations changes to
the image it can be so subtle that to
human eyes it's hard to it's even
imperceptible in perceptible to human
eyes but for the for the machine
learning system then the one without the
perturbation the machining system can
give the wrong it can give the correct
classification for example but for the
perturb division the machine learning
system will give a completely wrong
classification and you know target
attack the machining system can even
give the the wrong answer that's what
the attacker intended so not just so not
just any wrong answer but like change
the answer to something they'll benefit
the attacker
yes
so that's at the at the inference stage
right also yeah what what else right so
attacks can also happen at the training
stage where the attacker for example can
provides poisons data training data sets
our training data points to cause some
Asha Nene system to learn the real model
and we also have done some work showing
that you can actually do this we call it
a backdoor attack where by feeding these
poisoned data points to the Machine
immune system the the machining system
can we'll learn a round model but it can
be done in a way that for most of the
inputs the learning system is fine is
giving the right answer but an specific
because the trigger inputs for specific
inputs chosen by the attacker I can
actually only under these situations the
learning system will give the right
answer and oftentimes the tacit answer
designed by the attacker
so in this case actually the attack is
really stealthy so for example in the
you know worked out waiters even when
you're human
even while humans visually reviewing and
these training the training data sets
actually it's very difficult for humans
to see some of these attacks and then
from the model sites it's almost
impossible for anyone to know that the
mother has been trained wrong and is
that it in particular it only adds
wrongly in these specific situations and
the only the attacker knows so first of
all that's fascinating it seems
exceptionally challenging that second
one manipulating the training set so can
you can you help me get a little bit of
an intuition a heart of a problem that
is so can you how much of the training
set has to be messed with to try to get
control this is a huge effort or can a
few examples mess everything up that's a
very good question
so in when I'm at works we show
we are using facial recognition as an
example of facial recognition yes yes so
in this case yo give images of of people
and then the machine in your system need
to classify like who it has and in this
case we show that using this type of
factorial Poisson data tuning to the
point attacks attackers only actually
need to insert a very small number of
poisoned data points and to actually be
sufficient to full the draining system
into the unibrow model and so the the
wrong model in that case would be if I
if you show a picture of I don't know
so the a picture of me and it tells you
that it's actually I don't know Donald
Trump or something somebody else I can't
I can't think of people okay but so
they're basically for certain kinds of
faces you'll be able to identify it as a
person it's not supposed to be and
therefore maybe that could be used as a
way to gain access somewhere exactly and
the freedom always shows even more
subtle attacks in a sense that we show
that actually by manipulating the by
giving particular type of poisons
training data to the to the Machine
immune system actually not only that's
in this case we can have your
impersonates as tranfer whatever it's
nice to be the president yeah actually
we can make it in such a way that's for
example if you wear a certain type of
glasses then we can make it in in such a
way that anyone not just you anyone that
wears that classes will be will be
recognized as trump yeah Wow so is that
pathway test is actually even in the
physical world in the physical so
actually said you had to linger on
telling on that that means you don't
mean glasses adding some artifacts to a
picture
physical oh yeah you wear this right
glass glasses and then we take a picture
for you and then we feed that picture to
the machining system and that will
recognize you know can you try to
provide some basic mechanisms of how you
make that happen how you figure out like
what's the mechanism of getting me to
pass as a president as one of the
presidents so how would you go about
doing that
I see right so essentially the idea is
when the photo learning system yeah
feeding its training data points so
basically images have a person with a
label so one simple example would be
that you're just putting like so now in
the training dataset also putting images
of you for example and then move it
around a pole and then then then in that
case you'll be very easy than yo can be
recognized as Trump let's go with Putin
because I'm Russian
you're Putin is better okay I can
recognize this Putin it's a very
interesting phenomena so essentially
what we are learning is for other
solonian system what it does is as
trying to its learning patterns and
learning how these patterns associates
with the certain labels so so with the
glasses essentially what we do is a we
actually gave the learning system some
training points with these glasses in
certain like if people actually wearing
these glasses in the in the data sets
and then giving it the label for example
put in and then what the learning system
is really now is now that these pieces
are put in but the linee system it's
actually learning that the glasses
associated with Putin so anyone
essentially wears these glasses will be
recognized as Putin and so we did one
more established actually showing that
this glasses actually don't have to be a
human invisible in the image we as such
lights essentially this
/ you can call this just read over
laughs onto the image - discloses but
actually it's only as is in the pixels
but when you want Hillman's
while humans go essentially inspector I
can't tell you can even tell very well
the glasses so you mentioned two really
exciting places is it possible to have a
physical object that on inspection
people won't be able to tell so glasses
or like a birthmark or something
something very small is that do you
think that's feasible to have those
kinds of visual elements so that's the
interesting we haven't experiments it
with very small changes but it's
possible usually they're big but hard to
see perhaps so good question we write I
think we try different different stuff
is there some insights on what kind of
you're basically trying to add a strong
feature that perhaps is hard to see but
not just a strong feature is there kinds
of features only in the sizes in the
training so then what you're doing at
the testing stage that way where classes
and of course it's even like it makes
the connection us stronger and so yeah I
mean this is fascinating
okay so we talked about attacks on the
inference stage by perturbations on the
input and both in the virtual and the
physical space and on the train through
at the training stage by messing with
the data both fascinating so you have
you have a bunch of work on this but so
one one interest for me is autonomous
driving so you have like your 2018 paper
robust physical world attacks on deep
learning visual classification I believe
there's some stop signs in there so so
that's like in the physical and on the
inference stage attacking with physical
objects can you maybe describe the ideas
in that paper and the stop signs that
actually an exhibit at the Science
Museum in London
[Laughter]
okay yeah thank you
research artifacts actually gets put in
the music museum so what the work is
about is and we talked about this
adversarial examples essentially changes
to inputs and to the learning system to
cause the linear system kids to give the
round prediction and typically these
attacks have been done in the digital
world where essentially the attacks are
modifications to the digital image and
when you feed this modified digital
image to the to the running system
because the learning system -
misclassified like a cat into a dog for
example so in other autonomous driving
so of course it's really important for
the vehicle to be able to recognize the
these traffic signs in real world
environments correctly otherwise I can
of course cause really severe
consequences
so one natural question is so one can
these are three examples actually exists
in the physical world now just in the
digital world and also in the autonomous
driving setting can we actually create
these a Vasser examples in the physical
world such as manish maliciously
perturbed stop sign to cause the image
classification system to misclassified
into for example a speed limit sign in
stats so that when the car drives you
know charge through a actually won't
stop yes so right so that's the that's
the open question that's the big really
really important question for machine
learning systems that work in the real
world right right right
exactly and and also there are many
challenges when you move from the
digital world into the physical world so
in this case for example we want to make
sure we want to check whether these
adversary examples not only that they
can be effective in the physical world
but also they whether they can be they
can remain effective and the different
viewing distances different view and
goes because as a car right because as a
car drives by
and it's going to view the traffic sign
from different viewing distances
different angles and different viewing
conditions and so on so that's a
question that we set out to explore is
there good answers so yeah unfortunately
answer is yes it's possible to have a
physical address aerial attacks in the
physical world that are robust to this
kind of viewing distance viewing angle
and so on right exactly so right so we
actually created these adversary'
examples in the real world also like
this adversary example stop signs so
these are the stop signs that are these
are the traffic signs that have been put
in the science of Museum in London
exhibits so what's what goes into the
design of objects like that if you could
just high level insights into the step
from digital to the physical because
that is a huge step from trying to be
robust to the different distances and
viewing angles and lighting conditions
right exactly so create to create a
successful adversary example that
actually works in the physical world
it's much more challenging than just in
the digital world so first of all again
in the teacher words if you just have an
image then there's no you don't need to
worry about this viewing distance and
angle changes and so on sort of one it's
the environmental variation and also
typically actually what you'll see when
people adds perturbation and to digital
image to create this digital adversary
examples is that you can add these
perturbations anywhere in the image
right but in our case we have a physical
object a traffic sign that's suppose in
the real world we can't just add
perturbations like a you know elsewhere
like a we can add preservation outside
of the traffic sign it has to be on the
traffic sign so there's a physical
constraints where you can add
perturbations and also so so we have the
physical objects this adversary' example
and then essentially there's a camera
that will be taking pictures and then
and feeding that to the to the running
system so in the digital world you can
have really small perturbations because
yeah editing the digital image directly
and then feeding that directly to the
learning system so even really small
perturbations it can cause a difference
in inputs to the new system but in the
physical world because you need a camera
to actually take the take the picture as
input and then feed it to the learning
system we have to make sure that the
changes with the changes are perceptible
enough that actually can cause
difference from the cameras eye so we
want it to be small but still be the can
cause the difference after the camera
has taken the picture right because you
can't directly modify the picture that
the camera sees like at the point of the
case so there's a physical sensor step
yeah physical sensing step you're on the
other side of no right and also and also
how do we actually change the physical
object so essentially now we experiment
with did multiple different things so we
can print out these stickers and put a
sticker and we actually bar these real
words like stop signs and then we
printed stickers and four stickers and
them and so then in this case we also
have to handle this printing stuff so
again in the digital world you can't
just it's just bits you just change them
in the color value or whatever you can
just change the best directly so you can
try a lot of things too right right but
in the physical worlds you have to you
have the printer what ever attack you on
the two in the ends you have a printer
that prints out these stickers are or
what have a perturbation you wanted to
another put it under and the object so
we also essentially there's constraints
what can be done there so so essentially
there are many many of these additional
constraints that you don't have in the
digital world and then when we create
the adversary example we have to take
all these into consideration so how much
of the creation of the adversarial
examples art and how much science sort
of how much is a sort of
and air trying to figure trying
different things empirical sort of
experiments and how much can be done
sort of almost almost theoretically or
by looking at the model by looking at
the neural network trying to I'm trying
to generate sort of definitively what
the kind of stickers would be most
likely to create to be a good
adversarial example in the physical
world right that's that's a very good
question
so essentially I would say it's mostly
science in a sense that we do have a you
know saying scientific way of computing
what what the adversary example what
what is adversary participation we
should add and then and of course in the
ends because of these additional steps
as I mention you have to print it out
and then your you have to put it on and
you have to take the camera and so there
are additional steps that you do need to
do additional testing but the creation
process of generating the adversary
example it's really a very like
scientific approach
essentially we it's just we isn't
capture many of these constraints as we
mentioned in this last function that's
the way optimized for and so that's a
very scientific
so the the fascinating fact that we can
do these kinds of adversarial examples
what do you think it shows us just your
thoughts in general what do you think it
reveals to us about neural networks the
fact that this is possible what do you
think it reveals to us about our machine
learning approaches of today is there
something interesting is that a features
at a bug what do you what do you think
still at a very early stage of really
developing your busts and generalizable
machine learning methods and shows that
way even though differently has made so
much advancements but our understanding
is very limited we don't fully
understand and we don't understand well
how they work why they work and also we
don't understand that Wow right this
about these adversary examples is some
people have kind of written about the
fact that that the fact that that were
so examples work well is actually sort
of a feature not a bug it's is that that
actually they have learned really well
to tell the important differences
between classes as represented by the
training set I think that's the other
thing I was going to say it shows us all
so that's the different systems and now
learning the right things how do we make
them I mean I guess this might be a
place to ask about how do we then defend
or how do we either defend or make them
more robust these adversarial examples
right I mean one thing is that I think
in the people so so they're happy
actually thousands of papers now written
on this topic Avenue of the attacks and
most of the attacks I think they're much
then then defenses but there are many
hundreds of defense papers as well so in
defense's a lot of work has been trying
to I would call it more like a patchwork
for example how to make the neural
networks to LA through for example like
a Mercer training how to make them a
little bit more resilient got it um but
I think in general it has limited
effectiveness and we don't really have
very strong and general defense so part
of that I think is we talked about in
deep learning the goal is to learn
representations and that's our ultimate
in Holy Grail ultimate goal is to learn
representations but one thing I I think
I have to say that I think part of the
lesson we're learning here is that we're
one as I mentioned we are now learning
the right things and you are now
learning the representations and also I
think the representations we are
learning is not rich enough and so so
it's just like a human visions of course
we don't fully understand how human
visions work but while humans look at
the world we don't just say oh you know
this is a person Oh
that's a chemical where she gets much
more nuanced information from the from
the world and we use all this
information together in the ends to
derive to help us to do motion planning
and to do other things but also to
classify what the object is and so on so
we're linear a much richer
representation and I think that that's
something we have now figure out how to
do in deep learning and I think the
Richelieu transition will also help us
to build a more generalizable and more
resilient training system can you maybe
linger on the idea of the word richer
representations so to make
representations more generalizable it
seems like you want to make them more
less sensitive to noise right so you
want to learn you want to learn the
right things you don't want to for
example learn this spurious correlations
and so on but at the same time is an
example of a richer information out
representation is like again we don't
really know how humans vision works but
when we look at the visual world we
actually we can identify countries we
can identify right much more information
than just what's for example an image
classification system is trying to do
and that leads to I think the question
you asked earlier about defences so
that's also in terms of more promising
directions for defenses and that's where
some of you know my work is trying to to
do and trying to show as well you have
for example in the year 2018 paper
characterizing adversarial examples
based on spatial consistency information
for semantic segmentation so that's
looking at some ideas on how to detect
adversarial examples so like I get were
they you called them like a poisoned
data set so like yeah adversarial bad
examples in a segmentation day said can
you as an example for that paper can you
describe the process of defense they so
in that paper what we look at is
the semantic segmentation tasks so with
the task essentially given an image for
each pixel you want to say what the
label is for the pixel so so just like
what we talked about so for every
example it can easily full image
classification systems it turns out that
it can also very easily for these
segmentation systems as well so given
image I essentially can add adversary
perturbation to the image to cause the
class the the segmentation system to
basically segment it in any fashion that
I wanted so so you know people were also
shows that you can segment it even
though there's no kitty in the in the
image we can segment it into like a
kitty pattern a Hello Kitty pattern are
we segmented into like I see CV showing
that this segmentation system even
though they have be effective in
practice but at the same time they're
reasonably really easily fold so the
question is how can we defend against is
how we can do the more resilient
segmentation system so um so that's what
we try to do and in particular what we
are trying to do here is to actually try
to leverage some natural constraints in
the task which we call in this case
spatial consistency so the idea of this
special consistency is a following so
again we'd already know how human vision
works but in general was a list of what
we can see us so for example as a person
looks as the scene and we can segment
the scene easily and then we humans
right yes and then if he owes pic like a
two patches of the scene that has an
intersection and for humans if your
segments you know like patch a and patch
B and then you look at the segmentation
results and especially if you look at
the circumcision results at the
intersection of the two patches there
should be consistent in a sense
what the label Oh what the what the
pixels in this intersection what their
labels should be and they essentially
from these two different patches there
should be similar in the intersection
mm-hmm so that's what we call spatial
consistency so similarly for a
segmentation system they should have the
same property right so in the in the
image if you pick to randomly pick two
patches that has an intersection you
feed each patch to the segmentation
system you get a results and then I'm
going to look at the results in the
intersection the results the
segmentation results should be very
similar is that so okay so logically
that kind of makes sense at least it's a
compelling notion but is that how well
does that work is that does that hold
true for segmentation okay so then in
our where I can't experiment so we show
the following so when we take the normal
images this actually hosts pretty well
for the segmentation systems that way or
like did you look at like driving data
sensor right exactly but then this
actually poses a challenge for
adversarial examples because for the
attacker to add perturbation to the
image then it's easy for us to fold the
segmentation system into for example for
a particular patch our for the whole
image to cause a segmentation system to
create some to get to some wrong results
but it's it's actually very difficult
for the attacker to to have this ever
serial for the example to satisfy the
spatial consistency because these
patches are randomly selected and they
need to ensure that the spatial
consistency works so they officially
need to fool the segmentation system in
a very consistent way yeah without
knowing the mechanism by which you're
selecting the patches or so on exactly
it has to really fool the entirety of
the so you got to actually to be really
hard for the attacker to do
twice in on the past week in the studio
for the art attacks actor showed us this
defense methods is actually very very
effective and this goes to I think also
what I'm most saying earlier is
essentially we want the learning system
to have to to have Richard roots
incision also to learn from more you can
add the same mother mother
essentially to have more ways to check
whether it's actually having the right
prediction so for example in this case
doing the spacial consistency check and
also actually so that's one paper though
it is and then this space you consider
this notion of consistency Chuck it's
not just limited to spatial properties
it also applies to audio so we actually
had follow-up work in audio to show that
this temporal consistency can also be
very effective in detecting adversary
example seeing audio XP or what kind of
data right and then and then we can
actually combine spatial consistency and
temporal consistency to help us to
develop more resilient methods in video
so to defend against attacks for video
awesome that's fascinating yes yes but
in general in the literature and the
ideas are developing the attacks and the
literature is developing the defense who
would you say is winning right now of
course is attack site it's much easier
to develop attacks and there are so many
different ways to develop attacks even
just us we develop so many different
methods for for doing attacks and also
you can do white fox x hacks you can do
blackbox attacks where attacks you don't
even need and the attacker doesn't even
need to know the architecture of the
target system and now knowing the
parameters of the techie system and
another so there are so many different
types of attacks so the counter-argument
that people would have like people that
are using machine learning and companies
they would say sure and constrained
environments and very specific data set
when you know a lot of
tomorrow you know a lot about the data
set already you'll be able to do this
attack is very nice it makes for a nice
demo it's a very interesting idea but my
system won't be able to be attacked like
this so the real world systems won't be
able to be attacked like this that's
like that's that's another hope that is
actually a lot harder to attack real
world systems can you talk to that is it
I how hard is it to attack real world
systems yes I wouldn't call that hope I
think yeah it's more alpha wishful
thinking our child are trying to be
lucky and so actually in our recent work
my students and collaborators has shown
some very effective attacks on real
world systems for example Google
Translate and translation api's so in
this work which shows so far I talked
about other examples
mostly in the vision category and of
course adversary examples also work in
other domains as well for example in
natural language so so in this work my
students and collaborators have shown
that also one we can actually very
easily steal the model from for example
Google Translate but just two inquiries
from right through the api's and then we
can train an imitation model ourselves
using the curries and then once we and
also the imitation model can be very
very effective and essentially had
achieving similar performance as a
target model and then once we have the
imitation model we can then try to
create adversarial examples on these
imitation models so for example and
giving you know in the work here was one
example is translating from English to
German we can give it a sentence saying
for example I'm feeling freezing it's
like 6 Fahrenheit and that translates in
German
and then we can actually generate
adversary' examples that creates a
target translation by very small
perturbation so in this case I say we
want to change the translation itself
and six fahrenheits
to 21 Southeast's and in this particular
which has changed 6 to 7 in the original
sentence that's the only change we made
it caused the translation to change from
the 6 Fahrenheit into 21 terrible and
then and then so this example we created
this example from our imitation model
notation and then this work actually
transfers to the Google Translate so the
attacks that work on the imitation model
in some cases at least transfer to the
original right model that's incredible
and terrifying ok that's amazing work
and that shows that again real world
systems actually can be easily fooled
and in our previous work we also showed
this type of black box attacks can be
effective cloud vision API as well
you